THE ESTABLISHMENT WORLD AGAIN.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
A LOT ON THE LINE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NEWT GINGRICH.
I THINK THAT’S EVERYTHING WE
NEED TO HEAR FROM JOHN BOLTON
PER YOUR REACTION.
>> I THINK FIRST OF ALL, THEY
ARE GOING DOWN A TOTAL DEAD
ALLEY, BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO IMPOSE EXECUTIVE PEER
PRIVILEGE THAT WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO COURT.
THEY WANT TO DRAG THIS OUT
ANOTHER MONTH AGO, THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT, BUT THE
COUNTRY IS ALREADY OPPOSED TO
DRAGGING IT OUT.
DAVID AXELROD, WHO WAS A KEY
PERSON TO BARACK OBAMA, HAD A
RECENT COLUMN THAT SAID HE SAT
THROUGH A FOCUS GROUP OF
DEMOCRATS IN CHICAGO AND IT WAS
80 MINUTES, 80 MINUTES BEFORE
ANY OF THEM MENTIONED THE
IMPEACHMENT, AT WHICH POINT
EVERYONE IN THE GROUP SAID
THAT’S OVER, IT’S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN, I DON’T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
I SAID, DEMOCRATS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND, THIS IS NOT WORKING.
THE DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO BE VOTING
TO HAVE NO MORE WITNESSES.
THE DEMOCRATS, FRANKLY, WANT TO
VOTE TO CLOSE IT DOWN TOMORROW.
EVERY DAY THIS GOES ON, THE
DEMOCRATS LOOK SMALLER, MORE
POLITICAL, MORE DESTRUCTIVE OF
AMERICA, AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS NO REASON TO HAVE ANY MORE
WITNESSES, BECAUSE THERE’S NO
CASE.
LITERALLY, THERE IS NO CASE HERE
HERE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, JAY SEKULOW
SAID, THEY WERE WITNESSES THAT
HAD EITHER BEEN INTERVIEWED BY
DEPOSITION IN THE HOUSE
PROCEEDINGS, JURY PROCEEDINGS,
AND IT WAS SPECIFICALLY, YOU
KNOW, THOSE THREE PEOPLE.
THEY KNEW WITNESSES WERE NOT
BEING CALLED.
WHY WOULD ANY REPUBLICAN IN THE
SENATE WANT TO BREAK THAT
PRECEDENT.
>> I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANY
REAL REASON TO HAVE ANY NEW
PEOPLE COME IN.
THAT VIOLATES THE WHOLE POINT.
THIS IS NOT AN INQUIRY INTO WHAT
HAPPENED IN UKRAINE.
THIS IS AN IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
IN AN IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, THERE’S
A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
ARE THE ALLEGATIONS RISING TO
THE LEVEL THAT YOU WOULD DEPRIVE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF THE
PERSON THEY ELECTED AS
PRESIDENT?
NOW, I DON’T THINK A SINGLE ONE
OF THE REPUBLICANS BELIEVES THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
CONVICTED, SO I THINK IT IS AN
ABSOLUTE GAME FOR ANY OF THEM TO
VOTE YES TO HAVE MORE WITNESSES,
BECAUSE THE WITNESSES AREN’T
GOING TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
THIS IS NOT AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
WE HAVE A VERY GOOD WAY OF
SOLVING IT.
IT’S CALLED AN ELECTION, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, AND 279 DAYS, THE
REAL JURY, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WHO GET TO DECIDE.
MY HUNCH IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
REELECT TRUMP BY AN AMAZING
MARGIN.
BUT WHAT SCHIFF SAID THE OTHER
DAY IT WAS VERY CHILLING.
HE SAID, WE CAN’T LET THIS UP TO
THE VOTERS.
HE IS SUCH AN ARROGANT ELITIST,
HE THINKS HE IS MORE IMPORTANT
THEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE.
I WOULD HOPE THAT AFTER THEY
THINK ABOUT IT, THAT NOT A
SINGLE REPUBLICAN WILL HAVE ANY
MORE WITNESSES.
>> Sean: SCHIFF ACTUALLY SAID
TODAY, NOT ALL QUID QUO PROS ARE
THE SAME.
NOBODY IS AS BAD AS JOE, I WOULD
ADD.
YOU’VE GOT SOME CORRUPT.
FOR ONE, YOU CAN ASK
JOHN BOLTON.
I WANT TO REPLAY WHAT BOLTON
SAID ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT ZELINSKY.
HE SOUNDS JUST LIKE THE WAY
DONALD TRUMP DESCRIBED HIM.
WARM, CORDIAL, AND THEY WERE
CONGRATULATORY.
HE AND THE PRESIDENT SPOKE TWICE
TWICE.
LET ME PLAY THIS TAPE, BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS ALL WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM JOHN BOLTON.
>> I WILL BE MEETING
PRESIDENT ZELINSKY.
HE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN TWICE.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED TO
CONGRATULATE PRESIDENT ZELINSKY
ON HIS ELECTION AND ON HIS
SUCCESS IN THE PARLIAMENTARY
ELECTION.
THEY WERE VERY WARM AND CORDIAL
CALLS.
THEY WERE HOPING THAT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO MEET IN WARSAW AND
HAVE A FEW MINUTES TOGETHER.
THE SUCCESS OF UKRAINE
MAINTAINING ITS FREEDOM, ITS
SYSTEM OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT, THE FREE MARKET
ECONOMY FREE OF CORRUPTION, AND
DEALING WITH THE PROBLEMS OF
CRIMEA ARE HIGH PRIORITIES HERE
BUT HIGHER PRIORITIES FOR THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL.
>> Sean: HE SAW NOTHING WRONG
WITH THE CALL THERE.
IT WAS VERY CLEAR.
THE FACTS NEVER CHANGE.
MAYBE WHATEVER DONALD TRUMP
SAID, THEY DID NOTHING.
THEY ANNOUNCED NOTHING.
THEY TOLD US HE DIDN’T ASK FOR
ANYTHING.
WHY ARE WE EVEN HERE?
>> WELL, WISHING TO BE HERE.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT.
I THINK THAT THERE WAS PRETTY
GOOD GROUNDS FOR HAVING THE
SENATE LITERALLY REJECT THE
PROPOSAL THE DAY IT CAME ACROSS.
I THOUGHT THE ARROGANCE AND THE
DISHONESTY OF BOTH SCHIFF AND
NADLER IN LECTURING THE SENATORS
ON WHAT THEIR DUTY WAS, WHICH BY
THE WAY, IS ABOUT AS DUMB A
THING AS YOU CAN DO IS INSULT
THE JURY, WHICH IS WHAT THEY
DID.
I THINK THAT THE RESULT HAS BEEN
THAT THEY FURTHER ALIENATED THE
REPUBLICAN SENATORS, AND I THINK
THEY HAVE NOW WEAKENED THEIR
POSITION WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
DEMOCRATS.
AND WHEN IT BE AT ALL SURPRISED
TO SEE A BIPARTISAN MAJORITY,
NOT JUST REPUBLICANS, BUT A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS VOTE THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GUILTY, IS
NOT IMPEACHABLE.